ينضم الينا الان من واشنطن الدكتور خليل
العناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه اهلا بك معنا الانبار تتجه بطبيعه
الحال الى تل ابيب مع وصول وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انتوني بلينكن برايك ما
الارضيه التي سيبني عليها وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي محادثاته مع
الاسرائيليه
لا نسمع صوت الدكتور خليل العناني سنعود
اليك بطبيعه الحال في حال انهاء المشكله
الفنيه نستمع السيد خليل تسمعني انا نعم
الان
اسمعك نبدا من جديد سيد خليل وسالتك عن
الارضيه التي سيبني عليها انتوني بلينكن
المحادثات مع
الاسرائيليين كنت اقول عبد السلام ان
الارضيه التي ينطلق منها بلينكن في كولته
الحاليه خاصه فيز اسرائيل تنطلق من
محاولته وجد او ايجاد نوع من الخروج من
هذه الازمه المتواصله وهذه الحرب الهمجيه
الدمويه على قطاع غزه على ما يبدو هناك
حاله تململ امريكي واضحه من التكلفه
الانسن عليها لهذه الحرب الامر الثاني من
عدم وجود افق سياسي لهذه الحرب والامر
الاكثر اهميه عدم وجود اي انجاز عسكري على
الارض نحن دخلنا الشهر الرابع حاليا لهذه
الحرب بنتكلم على حاله فشل ذريع
اسرائيلي سواء من خلال عدم انجاز اي تحقق
او اي تقدم على الارض عسكريا الامر الثاني
عدم القدره على تحرير الرهائن من خلال
العمليه العسكريه شهدنا بالامس محاوله
فاشله اخرى من اجل اطلاق سراح بعض الرهائن
لم تنجح على الاطلاق وبالتالي هناك حاله
احباط واضحه في واشنطن من استمر استمر هذه
الحرب وفي نفس الوقت تكليفه
الانسانيه العاليه جدا وفي ايضا التكلفه
السياسيه داخليا في امريكا هنا خاصه نحن
بدانا خلال الايام الماضيه موسم انتخابات
ساخن ومهم جدا انتخابات رئاسيه وتشريع
وبالتالي هناك محاوله امريكيه للبحث ولو
من من باب حفظ ماء الوجه عن مخرج من هذه
الحرب سواء من خلال تخفيض العمليه
العسكريه البريه الى عمليات جراحيه نوعيه
تقوم فيها اسرائيل باستهداف بعد قطل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه خاصه بحركه حماس او
من خلال وجود اطار او اتفاق قد يفضي بشكل
او باخر الى اخراج الرهائن
من الاسر الموجودين حاليا وبالتالي هي
محاوله في ظني انها لن تنجح لن يكتب لها
النجاح ستكون كسابقتها من جولات لسبب بسيط
ومهم وهو عدم وجود اراده امريكيه في الضغط
على اسرائيل لوقف هذه الحرب عدم وجود هذه
الاراده لكن لكن التصريحات عن انت لا تعول
على التصريحات التي نقلتها ان بي سي عن
مسؤول امريكي رفيع بان وزير الخارجيه
سيبلغ اسرائيل بضروره انهاء الحمله
العسكريه في في اقرب
وقت هو يا عبد السلام لا يجب ان يبلغ يجب
ان يضغط بشكل كامل يعني التبليغ هذا اضعف
الايمان يعني هو يتحدثون عن استحياء هم
يتحدثون باستمرار يستخدمون لغه فيها قدر
عالي من من الحذر والحيطه يقوللك توضيحات
نصائح رجاء رغبات لكن ليس هناك ضغط امريكي
ولغه قويه وجاده وحده في نفس الوقت لو انت
بالفعل وليس هناك اسمحلي فقط لانه لانه
تصريح بايدن قال بانه يعمل بهدوء مع
الحكومه الاسرائيليه لتشجيعها على تقليص
هجماتها في غزه والخروج منها صحيح لا يوجد
هناك ضغط او تلويح بامر ما سنقطع الدعم
العسكري او سنفعل ذلك او ابعد من ما يحصل
مثلا مع دول اخرى بفرض عقوبات لكنه يقول
نتحدث بهدو وهنا السؤال عن التوازنات
الامريكيه في التعامل مع حكومه ترى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه انها تضم
عناصر مثل بنفير و سموتريتش وغيرهم ممن لا
ترغب في وجودهم لكن عليها ان تتعامل معهم
على اات
حال المشكله الاسيه عبد السلام ان هذا
الهدوء يفهم من قبل اسرائيل باعتباره ضعفا
وترددات ازازا امريكيا يفهم انه ليس هناك
قدره امريكيه على الضغط يفهم انه اعطاء
للور الضوء الاخضر وبالتالي انت في وقت
الاوقات يجب ان تظهر بعضا من الجديه بعض
من الضغوط الجاده الحقيقيه كي تاخذ ب على
محمل الجديه لكن انت بتتكلم على ثلاث شهور
من كلام امريكي معسول للمجتمع الدولي
متعلق
بوقف الهجمات على المدنيين وقف التكلفه
المرتفعه للمدنيين الحديث عن المساعده
الانسانيه لكن في نفس الوقت تقدم كل انواع
الدعم العسكري لاسرائيل يعني بالامس قام
بلينكن بظرف الدموع دموع التماسيح على
وفاه نجل الزميل العزيز وائد الدحدوح مره
يعني قال انه هذا امر مؤلم لانه مر بهذه
التجربه مرتين وهو يعلم جيدا ان ربما يكون
حمزه الدحدوح قد قتل بصاروخ امريكي جاء من
خلال بلينكن نفسه الذي قام قبل حوالي
اسبوع باعطاء مساعدات طارئه لاسرائيل
ووافق على ذلك متجاوزا الكونجرس الامريكي
من اجل دعم اسرائيل بذخائر وقنابل
وبالتالي هناك منطق اسرائيل كما قلنا
ازدواجيه نوع من العمى الذي اصاب اداره
بايدن يتحدثون شيء ويفعلون شيء اخر
وبالتالي اي كلام حول العمل بهدوء مع
اسرائيل فقط مجرد كلام للاستهلاك المحلي
استهلاك الاستهلاك العالمي وبالتالي لكن
هناك تحديات اخرى تتعلق بما قال بلينكن
بانه سينقله للاسرائيليين وهو ما تحدث به
الى القاده العرب وايضا في اليونان و
وتركيا فما الذي هو على المحك الان حقيقه
فيما يتعلق بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه
كطرف مهم للشرق الاوسط لهذه الدول وايضا
لحليفها الاستراتيجيه اسرائيل ما هو الامر
الذي على المحك بالنسبه لواشنطن
الامر اللي على المحك عبد السلام امر واحد
وواضح بشكل كبير جدا هو المتعلق بعدم
اتساع نطاق الحرب اقليميا هذا يعتبر تحدي
لامريكا لانه بيفتح جبهات صراع مختلفه
وهناك بالفعل اشتعال ولو جزء لهذه الجبهات
خاصه الجبهه اللبنانيه خاصه بعد اغتيال
صالح العرور واغتيال اليوم او بالامس
لقائد ميداني من حزب الله بنتكلم على
اشتعال نوعا ما للجبهه العراقيه والاكثر
اهميه هي الجبهه اليمنيه بنتكلم على ربما
نشهد خلال الفتره المقبله ضربات نوعيه
تقوم بها امريكا وحلفائها تحت ائتلاف حراس
الازدهار
لليمنين للحوثيين في اليمن هذا يعني فتح
جبهه للصراع لن تقف فقط عند حدود اليمن بل
قد تصل الى مرحله انه تهدد الملاحه
العالميه حتى في جنوب شرق اسيا وبالتالي
ما يعني يق امريكا هو الامر المتعلق
بكيفيه منع تصاعد او منع اتساق الحرب في
المنطقه دكتور خليل العناني استاذ العلوم
السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه من واشنطن
شكرا جزيلا لك